.
WE ARE AT THE SITE OF THE 2022
PATRIOT AWARDS AND WE BEGIN WITH
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ALERT.
♪ ♪
IT IS NOW OFFICIAL.
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT WON A
MAJORITY IN THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES -- NOW WON A
REPRESENTATIVES.
NANCY PELOSI'S RAY HAS BECOME --
RAY HAS COME TO AN END.
PRESIDENT TRUMP KICKED OF HIS
PRESIDENTIAL BID IN MAR-A-LAGO
WITH A SPEECH FILLED WITH POLICY
AND WHILE WE CAN'T PREDICT
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN 2024, WE CAN TAKE A LOOK
BACK.
JUST TWO YEARS AGO, AMERICANS
WERE RECOVERING FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND A BIG WAY.
GAS PRICES WERE LOW.
INTEREST RATES WERE LOW.
INFLATION WAS ALMOST
NONEXISTENT.
THE STOCK MARKET WAS SURGING.
AND THE SOUTHERN BORDER WAS
SECURE.
BUT IN TWO SHORT YEARS, UNDER
JOE BIDEN, THAT TRAJECTORY, NOW
HAS CHANGED AND IT HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY.
OUR COUNTRY IS NOW IN A
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE.
AMERICANS ARE SADLY SUFFERING
FROM VIOLENT CRIME AND
BACKBREAKING INFLATION AND
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES GET
LAYOFFS AT MAJOR CORPORATIONS
ARE NOW UNDERWAY AND IT IS
HAPPENING.
IT IS WIDESPREAD.
ABROAD EUROPE IS NOT TO DRINK ON
THE BRINK OF YET ANOTHER WORLD
WAR.
NOW THESE ARE MAJOR LIFE
ALTERING PROBLEMS AND YET
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT OFFERING ANY
SOLUTIONS AT ALL.
THEY ARE LYING.
THE EHRESMANN.
THEY ARE FEARMONGERING.
AND LIKE THIS IS SOME KIND OF
GAME.
THIS IS ALL BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THEY LIED ABOUT REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO TAKE AWAY YOUR SOCIAL
SECURITY.
THEY LIED ABOUT DEMOCRACY IS ON
THE BALLOT BUT THEY IGNORED THE
SOUTHERN BORDER OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THEY ALLOWED
UNFETTERED ACCESS TO ANYBODY.
THAT U.S. SET A BRAND-NEW RECORD
FOR ILLEGAL CROSSINGS AS WE HAVE
UP THERE ON THE SCREEN
2.76 MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THAT WERE APPREHENDED IN
2022.
AND THAT IS UP FROM LAST YEAR'S
RECORD OF ONE POINT SEVENTH
2 MILLION.
IN 2009, BORDER CROSSINGS WERE
556,000.
LET'S TAKE A QUICK LOOK IN TIME.
CHUCK SCHUMER HAD THIS TO SAY.
TIMES HAVE CHANGED.
>> ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS WRONG.
UNTIL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONVINCED THAT WE WILL STOP
FUTURE IT FLOWS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, WE WILL MAKE NO
PROGRESS.
ON DEALING WITH THE MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE HERE
NOW AND ON -- OUR SYSTEM OF
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE UNITED
STATES WITHOUT OUR PERMISSION
ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS AND ILLEGAL
ALIENS SHOULD NOT BE TREATED THE
SAME AS PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
U.S. LEGALLY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL NEVER
ACCEPT IMMIGRATION REFORM UNLESS
THEY TRULY BELIEVE THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS COMMITTED TO
ENDING FUTURE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> Sean: WHERE DID THAT GUY GO?
THAT IS WHEN THE DEMOCRATS CARED
ABOUT TRUTH AND REALITY AND
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
WE HAVE LAWS ABOUT INTEGRATING
INTO THIS COUNTRY AND YESTERDAY
AND IT WOULDN'T ATTEMPT TO
PANDER TO HIS MEDICAL BASE,
CHUCK SCHUMER SOUNDED VERY
DIFFERENT GRANTING AMNESTY TO
ALL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
DOES THIS SOUND LIKE THE SAME
GUIDE THAT YOU HEARD FROM?
YOU DECIDE.
>> Senator Schumer: OUR GOAL IS
TO HELP THE DREAMERS, A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
HOWEVER MANY UNDER COMMITTED
THERE ARE AND WE WILL BE
PURSUING THAT IN THE NEXT
SENATE.
IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT IS THE MORAL THING TO DO.
IT IS THE HUMANE THING TO DO AND
I WANT TO ASSURE EVERYONE HERE,
WE WILL NOT STOP FIGHTING UNTIL
WE GET A FIX FOR DACA.
>> Sean: WHY WAS NOT CHUCK
TELLING YOU THAT BEFORE THE
ELECTION?
LEGAL IMMIGRATION IS WRONG,
PLAIN AND SIMPLE UNTIL THE
EMERGENT PEOPLE ARE CONVINCED
THAT WE WILL STOP FUTURE FLOWS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WE WILL MAKE NO PROGRESS ON
DEALING WITH MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE NOW HERE.
SO IS EVERYONE DOES ANYONE
CONVINCED DEMOCRATS WILL STOP
FUTURE FLOWS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION?
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT AT
ALL?
HAVE THEY PROPOSED ANY KIND OF
SOLUTION?
WHAT THEY INHERITED WAS A SECURE
BORDER.
HOW IS KAMALA HARRIS DOING?
WHAT ABOUT HELMET SECURITY
SECRETARY MAYORKAS?
WHAT IS HE DOING TO HELP?
WHAT ON EARTH IS HE UP TO
BECAUSE HE IS NOT SECURING THE
HOMELAND AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER,
OUR COUNTRY IS AT RISK BECAUSE
OF WHAT IS A CLEAR ELECTION OF
DID HE.
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
THEY PROCESS, THEY RELEASE THEM
INTO THE COUNTRY.
THEY GIVE THEM PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A VACCINE MANDATE.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE A COVID
TEST.
THERE'S NO BACKGROUND CHECK
WHERE PEOPLE COME FROM WHETHER
THEY HAVE MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS
WERE NOT.
AND THEN TO GET THEIR FREE BIDEN
PHONE ENTITY -- AND TO GET
TRANSFERRED TO SOME OBSCURE
AIRPORT AND FROM THERE, IT WILL,
YOU TAKE CARE OF THEIR HOUSING
AND THEIR FOOD AND THEIR
HEALTHCARE AND THEIR EDUCATION
AND THEIR KIDS, ET CETERA.
AND LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
AMERICANS NOW THAT ARE DYING.
RECORD NUMBERS FROM FENTANYL
POURING IN FROM MEXICO.
90% OF HERE WHEN FROM THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER.
CARTELS ARE IMPORTANT.
KNELT MAKING MORE MONEY THEN
EVER.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, SEX
TRAFFICKING ARE RAMPANT.
CRIMINALS APPREHENDED TRYING TO
CROSS AND WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW
MANY WERE NOT APPREHENDED.
THAT WOULD MEAN TIMBER CELLS
WHEN TRYING TO GET INTO THIS
COUNTRY TO BRING OUR COUNTRY
HARM, TO BRING FAMILIES ARM.
THIS ADMINISTRATION, MAYORKAS,
BIDEN, I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW
THEY SLEEP AT NIGHT KNOWING THAT
THIS IS THE PUSHY OR INCOMPETENT
TECH IT IS NOW LED TO THE DEATH
AND DISRUPTION ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ESPECIALLY WITH FENTANYL
ON A MASSIVE SCALE.
WE KNOW THAT THE BIG GUY, JOE
BIDEN, SLEEP JUST FINE.
PLENTY OF NAPS AND EARLY
BEDTIME.
JOE IS NOT A SERIOUS PRESIDENT.
HE IS NOT UP TO TO DROP PRETTY
IS FEEBLE.
HE IS COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED AND
DEMOCRATS JUST TAUGHT HIM OUT
WITH A NOTE CARD IN HIS HEAD.
HE TELLS THE PARTY LINE, WHO IS
ACTUALLY MAKING THE REAL POLICY,
NO ONE SEEMS TO KNOW.
DEVOYD OF STRONG COVETED
RELATION -- LEADERSHIP.
IT IS ALSO THE INFLATION CRISIS.
IF YOU IT EVERY TIME YOU GO TO
EVERY STORE YOU SHOP AT.
THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
THE VIOLENCE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IN SMALL TOWNS, BIG CITIES.
BUT NOT YET WE DO HAVE GOOD
NEWS.
THE MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS NOW
IN THE HOUSE, THEY CAN AT LEAST
STOP THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
FROM ACTIVELY MAKING THESE
CRISIS EVEN WORSE.
AND NOW WHAT, TRILLION DOLLAR
NEW GREEN NEW DEAL, THEY CAN BE
ESTOPPED.
NO MORE DILUTE STATE BAILOUTS.
THAT CAN BE STOPPED.
NO MORE TAX HIKES.
THEY CAN STOP THAT.
AND BY THE WAY, THAT ALL GET --
GETS PASSED ON TO YOU.
THEY PASS IT ALL ONTO YOU.
REPUBLICANS HAVE THE POWER OF
SUBPOENA.
THEY HAVE THE POWER TO
INVESTIGATE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND ISSUE THOSE
SUBPOENAS AND HOLD ALL OF THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
TAKING CONTROL OF THE HOUSE
TONIGHT IS A REALLY BIG DEAL.
AND OUR TWO-YEAR NIGHTMARE WITH
RADICAL DEMOCRATS IN CONTROL OF